we've been having this discussion about
what will be necessary to prevent the
incoming Trump administration from doing
bad things and we've had a conversation
about what some of those things may be
that's not what I want to talk about
today here I want to talk about what the
strategies will have to be from
independent media and it's increasingly
clear that corporate media is not going
to be actively criticizing or even
issuing a a sort of serious critique of
what Donald Trump plans to say including
lies and what I mean by that is we'll
start with one example on NBC's Meet the
Press
over the weekend Wall Street Journal
editor-in-chief
Gerard Baker was asked about will you
call out Donald Trump's lies when Trump
lies and we know Trump lies like many
politicians have never been able to do
so before - to quote George W Bush uh we
don't always see the lies called what
they are here's what Gerard Baker said
and I warn you it's very very disturbing
do you feel comfortable saying someone's
a lie to be that depth debt you know if
somebody says just an outright false so
do you say the word lie is that
important to start putting in reporting
or not you know it's a good I'd be
careful about using the word lie lie
implies much more than just saying
something that's false it implies a
deliberate intent to mislead I think
it's perfectly went on when Donald Trump
says thousands of people were on the
rooftops of New Jersey on 9/11
celebrating thousands of Muslims where
they're celebrating I think it's I think
it's right to investigate that claim to
report what we found which is that
nobody found any evidence of that
whatsoever and to say that I don't I
think I think it's then up to the reader
to make up their own mind to say this is
what Donald Trump says this is what a
reliable trustworthy news organization
reports and you know what I don't think
that's true I think if you start
ascribing um a moral intent as it were
to someone by saying that they've lied I
think you run the risk that you look
like you are being you're not being
objective and I think
and I do think also it applies the
people this is this is happening all the
time now people are looking at what
don't some saying said this is false
suppose claim I think people say well
you know what Hillary Clinton said a lot
of things were false I don't recall the
press being quite so quite so concerned
about saying that she lied so what
Hillary Clinton has to do with it I have
no idea we're now nearly two months past
the election of Donald Trump Hillary
Clinton is nowhere to be found no clue
what she has to do with any of this so
Gerard Baker's making this into more of
a semantics and definition thing right
the word lie includes an intent you know
it's not true and you say it anyway
presumably to mislead or deceive versus
you miss stated a fact which could come
from ignorance you can't know the intent
so you can't call them lies but will
report inaccuracies not bad right well
no not really what Gerard Baker is
suggesting is pussyfooting around we
have not found evidence that what Donald
Trump alleges is true Donald Trump's
lies at our side are at such a level
that this is not going to cut it and
other media outlets have not hesitated
to call them lies the New York Times
MSNBC a New York Magazine The Washington
Post oh well they don't matter because
they're just liberal serious media like
The Wall Street Journal which is by the
way owned by News Corporation which is
the company that owns Fox News as well
they are going to be better because we
don't know what Donald Trump's intent is
when Donald Trump claims that the
unemployment rate is really 42 percent
when it's five percent we're going to
say we've not been able to find evidence
that the unemployment rate is 42 percent
and let the public decide when Donald
Trump claimed with no evidence that he
could save 300 billion dollars a year
from the Medicare Medicare prescription
drug program that only cost seventy
eight billion up which it should should
news outlets say we've not found
evidence based on just knowing that 78
is a smaller number than 300 that this
is actually possible but viewers and
readers should judge for themselves and
of course drug Baker mentioning the
entire people thousands dancing on the
rooftops of September 11 we have to
refresh the difference between
politician lies versus lying lies I
defend and I'm completely okay with when
you hear a politician lie so what's a
politician lie a politician lie would be
for example uh we've seen significant
increases to the deficit in the area of
XYZ under President Obama well okay you
know it's that's not a lie lie that's a
politician lie where when you look into
it you might be able to construct a
scenario by excluding counter
information where during specific dates
your claim might be true even though
it's totally out of context and not
really representative of what's going on
when you say the unemployment rate is 42
percent when it's actually 5 percent
that is not a politician lie that is a
lying lie and you need to be able to
call that out now there's another
possibility which is if you do not say
with certitude that Donald Trump is
lying there's only one other possible
belief which is that Donald Trump is
utterly ignorant about issues he should
know something about as president of the
United States so if you refuse to call
them lies then you need to explain that
Trump is a dangerously clueless buffoon
and there's obviously no way that the
Wall Street Journal is going to do that
and Dan Rather is having absolutely none
of this he posted to his Facebook page
the other day quote a lie is a lie is a
lie journalism as it was taught as I was
taught uh is a process of getting as
close to uh some valid version of the
truth as is humanly possible and one of
my definitions of news is information
that the powerful don't want you to know
so this statement from the
editor-in-chief of the Wall Street
Journal about how his papal route paper
will report on Donald Trump's potential
future lies is disturbing deeply
disturbing it is not the proper role of
journalists to meet lies especially from
someone of Trump's stature and power by
hiding behind semantics and euphemisms
our role is to call it as we see it
based on solid reporting when something
is in fact
a demonstrable lie it is our
responsibility to say so there is dan
Rather Pat pointing out what I pointed
out that this is a semantic game and
that it's not going to cut it I think
that's a really high expectation uh in
terms of the burden of proof to call
someone out for a lie you have to
knowingly have some idea that they had
intent behind what they were saying but
if you look at some of the examples that
Donald Trump has said in the past few
months on the campaign trail yeah
they're clear evidences of that I mean
he said that uh he lost personal friends
on 9/11 hundreds of them young you when
you asked can you name just one of them
he can't do it that's a clear example of
a lie yeah and there's some areas where
you I I said that the alternative to
these being lies are that he really just
doesn't know and that should also be
reported but with Pat's example for for
example are we arguing that Donald Trump
deliberately lied about losing hundreds
of friends on 9/11 or are we saying he
actually exists in the world thinking he
lost hundreds of friends on 9/11 when
it's not true that's actually just as
concerning if he is personally that
clueless about what the reality of the
situation is also last thought on this
there are these things called editorials
in the Wall Street Journal is the
argument that the Wall Street Journal
won't call Donald Trump out for lies in
supposed reporting pieces or are they
also saying when we do editorials about
the president which obviously that
something the Wall Street Journal does
is the second biggest newspaper in the
United States they're also going to hide
behind these semantic differences and
euphemisms there as well what's
abundantly clear is we can't count on
corporate media that's why we're raising
money at david pakman.com slash donate
to increase and engage a progressive
progressives in actions that will
actually make a difference and this is
why increasingly you are right to be
skeptical of corporate media thanks for
watching this video before you watch the
next one remember we're raising money to
expand the David Pakman show big league
as well as expand progressive activism
go to david pakman.com slash donate
donations of any size are much
appreciated